hi good morning and welcome to the video
for cybersecurity certifications in the
previous video we have discussed the job
profiles and we had tried to map them
with the certifications themselves here
we are going to discuss more of the
certifications what those certifications
mean how the exams are conducted and
their price points so importance of the
cybersecurity certification first and
foremost when I see a certification I
look at it from three different aspects
the first is the training itself which
allows me to gain the knowledge which
allows me to understand the aspects of
security or whatever the certification
is therefore the second aspect is the
exam itself how do I need to prepare
myself for the exam and how do I need to
approach the exam how do I need to
ensure that I pass in my first attempt
and the third aspect is the
certification itself which allows me to
be eligible to apply for a particular
job rule so obtaining a cybersecurity
certification ensures or shows to the
organization that you are applying to
that you do have the pretty requisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific rule for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a
cybersecurity certification will have
better employment opportunities because
they can showcase their knowledge with
the certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into managerial or
advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
credentials can be classified in three
different aspects the first one being
the foundational level then the
managerial level and that one's level in
the previous video we just had a small
overview here you're going to discuss
about what the certification covers how
the exams are kind
and the price points for each and every
exam so let's start with the
foundational certifications we start off
with CCNA which is the basic
certification for networking so the CCNA
routing and switching certification
basically it helps you build your
networking career you will join an
organization as a networking engineer
where you can help the organization
establish the routing the pathing of how
data packets will travel across the
network this certification covers all
the basic concepts that you require to
understand networking the basic
requirements for a certification are
that the candidate must have a
bachelor's degree but apart from that
there are no other prerequisites so it's
just that you need a bachelor's degree
and then you can apply you can study for
this you can undergo a training and then
you can attempt the exam the
certification provider obviously is
Cisco so the knowledge that is limited
to this training and certification is
for Cisco devices only the exam fees for
this certification is approximately
three hundred and twenty-five dollars
the exam when it is conducted it has
around fifty to sixty odd questions
which need to be answered in ninety
minutes the type of questions that you
are going to get is multiple choice
questions where you have a question and
four answers and you have to choose the
correct answers among those
drag-and-drop where you have to click on
an object and drag it to its appropriate
place probably architectural diagram and
you have to let's say pick on a router
and place it into a particular position
if you place it correctly you answer the
question correctly otherwise it's wrong
and a simulator where you where there
could be a configuration you need to
configure it in a particular manner and
then check whether the configuration is
correct or not the path mark is around
800 to 850 out of a possible thousand
marks so each question will have a
different rate age depending on the
depth of the question depending on the
difficult level of the question or the
difficulty level of the question which
would then count towards your marks and
if you score 800 to 850 that's when you
clear the exam the job roles as we have
discussed over here would be more more
on the network administrator side or a
network engineer side depending on the
level of experience that you have the
salaries that are expected from this job
rules in the US around $55,000 to
$90,000 annually the next one is the
conscious
occasion called Security+ come share is
also a global certification Authority
for InfoSec courses so this
certification teaches candidates on how
to secure applications networks and
devices
it focuses on hands-on practical skills
in the field of network security I have
trained people on this certification
myself so I know the certification is
quite hands-on it deals with the
concepts to the core it helps you
understand the concepts and then in the
practical hands-on demo you need to
execute the practical yourself so that
you can gain that knowledge the
recommended level for a candidate to
attempt this training would be at least
around 2 years of experience in the IT
sector in addition if you have already
been certified for Network+
certification from CompTIA which is the
baseline networking certification this
is also a preferred way to go for this
certification
I said come choice the certificate
provider and the exam fees for this
certification is 339 dollars the exam is
quite simple 90 questions in 90 minutes
that's one minute per question it sounds
like a lot of time but believe me the
questions can be a little bit confusing
can be a little bit lengthy so you will
require all those 90 minutes to answer
those questions especially when they are
tricky and they're technical in nature
the questions would be multiple choice
and performance based the pass mark for
this exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900 the job profiles for this
campus certification is when you want to
apply for a security analyst position or
a security engineers position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are ongoing in the organization the
average annual salary of this person
would be around 72 thousand dollars then
comes the ceh or the certified ethical
hacker training from EC Council now this
is a very well-known course and also a
PC Council is a global certifying
authority very well accepted across a
lot of countries this is an offensive
certification so here you're basically
trying to become a penetration tester
you're taught how to hack
you're taught how to attack a particular
organization from an ethical hackers
perspective so the job profiles that
you'll be looking here are of a pen
tester where you go into an organization
you test their security controls or you
will test their devices fine
flaws within them and then provide
recommendations of how to plug those
flaws or mitigate those flaws and
improve the security of that
organization it is recommended that you
have two years of experience at least in
networking or security for these to
attempt this kind of trainings and
certifications again a basic
understanding of networking may be a
little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary before
attempting this certification the
certification provided is ec-council and
the exam fees for this certification is
$500 so the exam here would be 125
questions which needs to be attempted in
four hours and you will only get
multiple-choice questions in here now
4ch there are two exams one is the
multiple-choice questions and the second
is a practical exam where you need to
solve some given problems to you in a
iLab scenario and if you are able to
solve them properly you then get
certified 4ch practical the cutoff
varies from 65 to 85 percent depending
on the questions that you have answered
in the weight age associated with each
and every question as said the job roles
would be as a penetration test or a
security engineer and your salaries
would start from around $90,000 annually
then comes the C and the other certified
network defender also from EC council
now this is more on the network defense
site so here again the job roles would
be where you're where there's a network
that you have and you're going to try to
secure the network and the
communications that are going to travel
over the network so you need to be a
network administrator a network security
engineer or as in a similar profile to
understand how networks work and then
you're going to attempt to secure those
networks the certificate provider again
is ec-council and the certification is
placed a little bit below CH so it
becomes network defense then CH where
you're going to become a penetration
tester the exam fees for this
certification is 350 US dollars the exam
the exam is of 100 questions to be
answered in four hours
again it's just a multiple-choice
questions so you get a question with
four options you answer the correct one
and you move on to the next question
the pass percentage against a varies
from 60 to 85 percent depending on the
questions answered and the wait age of
that question job rules to be applied
network defense technician C and the
analyst
or a security analyst from a network
perspective salaries would range from
65,000 to 75,000 dollars per annum
then comes the forensic investigator
course which is exactly what it is
digital forensic investigator this will
help you understand how computers work
where did I stored and how we can
retrieve that data to investigate a
crime that has taken place so the
candidate must have at least two years
of experience in the information
security sector they need a good
understanding of how networks work how
computers work how operating systems
work how they stored it out the location
where that data is stored how databases
work how those databases store those
data and so on so for this certification
is sought after more mainly in the law
enforcement areas but there are a few
corporates that offer forensic
investigation as a service especially
when corporate gets compromised and they
want to conduct their own investigations
the certification provider for this is
also ec-council
and the exam fees are $500 this is an
advanced level certification so
understanding of applications networks
and operating systems is a must before
you attend this the exam is quite
similar 150 questions in four hours
again it's just a multiple choice
question exam the cutoff again is from
60% to 85% depending on the questions
and the wait age of each and every
question job rules IT security
specialist network security Pro the job
roles forensic investigators law
enforcement agencies security
specialists homeland security jobs and
your salaries would be around eighty
eight thousand dollars and about all
right now let's talk about the
managerial level certifications
COBIT stands for control objectives for
information and related technologies
it's a certification that will give a
candidate an in-depth knowledge of the
framework where which ghupat is all
about and the framework helps you manage
and govern enterprise IT environments
now this is advanced certification so
around eight years of manageable
experience is suggested before you
attempt the core bit 5 certification to
understand all the aspects and to help
you implement the framework properly the
certification certificate provider is
Asaka the exam fees around $175 now this
is a small exam 50 questions but in 40
minutes so you really have to be
on your toes you have to know the
knowledge there is very limited time to
think and you have to be fast in your
answers the past percentage is 50% the
job roles associated with this
certification would be to when you apply
for information security manager or as a
security consultant or a cybersecurity
manager and your roles and
responsibilities would be to govern an
IT space that the organization owns so
all the servers that stops the network
the data flows the data bases everything
and how it needs to be managed and how
it needs to be kept governed in a secure
manner and your salaries would be around
a hundred thousand dollars plus then the
CISM also called that system it stands
for certified information security
manager and as the name suggests it's a
security manager certification it helps
the candidate in understanding the
relationship between business goals and
information security so now you're going
into the space where you are not only
technical in nature but you also have to
understand the business needs the goals
of the business and you have to align
the information security of your
infrastructure along with the business
needs and the business goals so it is
your inputs that are going to go to the
management to see if the infrastructure
is aligned to the business goals or if
the infrastructure or the business goals
need any fine-tuning around five years
of work experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the CISM out of the five
years the candidate must have a
background as an information security
manager for three years so you have some
experience as a manager you have
implemented those things yourselves
which will give you a better
understanding and then you attempt the
certification again providing by Asaka
and the exam fees for Asaka members is
five hundred and seventy five dollars
for non-members it is seven hundred and
sixty dollars the exam is where you have
to answer one hundred and fifty
questions in four hours quite a bit of
time but questions are going to be
scenario-based questions where they're
going to give you a lot of scenarios you
have to think about it and you have to
give the most probable and the correct
answer for that particular scenario the
pass mark is four hundred and fifty out
of 800 your job profiles would be either
a risk manager or a risk consultant
analyze
the business requirements to the
infrastructure security that that you
have and to identify if there any risks
associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around eighty eight thousand dollars and
about then the sisa or the C is a the
certified information systems auditor
certification it not only looks into
security but it also looks into auditing
and controls in information systems this
is a highly reputed certificate and you
gain a better understanding of
governance regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
five years of work the work experience
in the field of information systems
auditing control or security is
necessary now here the question would be
what's the difference security is very
your technical in nature you have done
let's say whenever the assessment or a
penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls IDS's IPSS data loss
prevention systems maybe even you TMS
and whatnot so experiencing architecting
or implementing those controls in an
effective manner mitigating your
security or EO
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that everything is
in place you're compliant with let's say
ISO 27001 guidelines all the policies
that you have created yourself and
everything is working in order so it's
more of a checklist where you're going
to just check everything is in place and
you're conforming to standards this
certification is also provided by Shaka
and the exam fees for Asaka members are
five hundred and seventy five dollars
whereas Nani Sarkar members will have to
pay for seven hundred and sixty dollars
for the certification 150 questions
again in four hours multiple choice
questions scenario based so you have to
really understand this real world
scenarios of where what controls and
what audit mechanism should be in place
passed mark is four hundred and fifty
out of eight hundred your job rules
would be mainly becoming an auditor or a
senior auditor or director for
information security
information audit manager or information
technology consultant where you provide
intelligence on how the company should
implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be one hundred and three
thousand and about then comes the CR is
see also no-go call desk risk certified
in risk and information systems control
certification helps the candidate design
and maintain Information Systems
controls for an organization this is one
of the most sought-after certifications
as far as risk management is concerned
in Europe and in the u.s. if you have
this kind of certifications you
automatically qualify for a risk manager
or a security risk manager or a
information security consultant kind of
role you should have a minimum of three
years of experience in the field of ice
controls that means information security
controls you should have knowledge about
firewalls you should know about how to
mitigate risks how to identify risks in
the first place
risk analysis risk management and after
which you are going to implement
security controls to mitigate that risk
or bring it to acceptable levels at this
point in time you will also be
responsible to create policies revolving
those risks and how you want to
calculate those risks and to treat those
risks in their lifetime so difficult
order again is Asaka five hundred and
seventy five dollars for sokka members
seven hundred sixty dollars for non
Asaka members for the exam fees a
similar question 150 questions to be
answered in four hours multiple choice
based on performances so they may give
you a scenario where you have to perform
a risk analysis and provide a report and
a solution based on your findings again
the past mock is four hundred and fifty
out of eight hundred the job profiles
associated as discussed earlier are the
IT risk management professionals where
they're going to identify risk
treat those risks calculate analyze
maybe do a business impact analysis to
ascertain how the organization is going
to be affected and then you will also be
looking at compliances as far as these
job roles are concerned average annual
salary would be one hundred and nineteen
thousand in a bow
moving on to advanced level
certification now this is where we come
across the CISSP or the sis
certification certified information
systems security professional this is
the gold standard of all certifications
if you have this certificate it's you
can basically be a
of a job in the IT world now just to
qualify you'll have to have five years
of experience in the information
security field there are eight domains
that are specified by cissp and you have
to prove that you have knowledge and
your work experience of around five
years in at least two of those domains
if you do not have those kind of
experiences you can still attempt the
exam but you become an associate of IC
square which means that you get six
years to accomplish the five years of
experience requirement for this
certification before taking up the
certification is suggested that the
candidate clears all the intermediate
level certifications not all but some of
them in fact I have seen people do the
other way around they qualify for CISSP
they give their exam once your cissp the
sisa or see some CIS your CIS m exams
are very easier to crack but you need to
have that kind of experience I have seen
people with 15 years of experience and
more feel at this certification in the
first attempt the certificate provided
is IC square the exam fees is six
hundred and ninety nine dollars like I
said this certification is where most
sought after the gold standard in fact
there is hardly any other certifications
after this that you might want to do the
questions now the exam has changed if it
is the English version that you're
giving it's 150 questions to be answered
in three hours if it is the non English
exam that you're attempting then it is
250 questions in six hours it's a
marathon and if you are opting for the
six hour exam you need to plan it really
well it sounds really easy but the
questions are quite tough the
scenario-based and the answers are quite
confusing as well you would get
multiple-choice questions you would get
drag and drop and you might get
simulators as well the past mark is 700
out of 1,000 but each question has a
different rate age so it depends on
which questions are asked of you and
which questions you have answered
correctly the job roles associated with
this certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so
information security manager risk
manager system information system
security officer the CEO role the CIA
chief information security officer any
role that you might think of as a risk
from a risk compliance strategy
could be achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is hundred and eight thousand dollars
for this certification that's it for
this video thank you for watching this
and I'll see in the next video thank you
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here